one of the midnight duties was to get
the morning meds ready Batman making
sure the right number of pinks and
whites and blues and yellows were the
proper containers labeled for whoever
got said pinks and whites and blues and
yellows on how I played musical chairs
with everyone's meant for a week oddly
enough there was no noticeable
difference in anyone's behavior so
seeking an alternative to pharmaceutical
therapy and just plain curious I decided
to see what would happen if I acting
crazier than the residence one day I
served everyone a slice of cake batter
another day I posted signs written in my
own private language lincolnís regular
staff didn't agree but I say that did
result in an improvement if only because
of a general increase in self-esteem I
can compared to me I figure they were
doing pretty good